The quickest way to ruin your relationship or marriage
is by not appreciating your partner
I just saw a TikTok about this girl saying that her husband came home from work
and she's a stay at home girlfriend
they don't have any kids
they just have a cat
and he tells her “it looks like you've done nothing all day”
and she's upset rightfully so
this is the way to ruin your relationship
by not appreciating each other
I'm the first person to give men the benefit of doubt
maybe he's had a hard day
but that still should never be taken out on your partner
That fairy that restocks the fridge
restocks toiletry restocks and cleans everything behind you
women are usually those fairies
okay if you want your partner
your little fairy to continue doing those things
I suggest you appreciate it
and never ever
ever tell your partner it looks like you've done nothing all day